well is all over the news today that
Robert Smith doing the commencement
exercise at Morehouse College
billionaire probably I think multi
billionaire is actually correct Robert
Smith did an incredibly outrageously
generous wonderful thing in the middle
of his commencement speech he announced
he was going to pay off all the student
loans of all the graduating class for
Morehouse for the year 2019 to say that
he's the most popular commencement
exercise speaker ever in the history of
man will be an understatement this guy
is incredible way to go don't know mr.
Smith but I am impressed
I love generous people generous people
make me smile generous people make you
smile sometimes they make our eyes leak
generosity is incredible outrageous
generosity is incredible apparently from
all the news reports he's family of
course is going to do grants to cause
this to happen as the way he announced
it and apparently they are going to pay
off some 40 million dollars worth of
student loans for the graduating class
of I guess that's his alma mater
probably and pretty incredible what a
wonderful thing and what a wonderful day
to be sitting there as a student with
student loan debt around your neck maybe
hopeless maybe overwhelmed and all of a
sudden that's just calling well not yet
but it's gonna be I mean wow absolutely
very very cool I mean we the people
taking care of we the people I'm getting
more and more and more disturbed about
our do-nothing Congress on the student
loan debt and every time I talk about
you can go to school debt-free and if
you choose the right school and you work
while you're in school choose an
inexpensive school in-state tuition you
work your tail off while you're in
school you do the things I get hate mail
I've been getting a lot of hate mail
from left-wing people who are feeling
the burn who just want the student loans
to all be forgiven and you know I just
did I've got Millennials coming in here
every day doing debt free screams paying
off their student loans you see I think
the federally insured and I'm really
kind of getting tired of you know people
saying well it's because you're white or
you know oh my god you don't know how I
grew up
you know the federally insured student
loan program is a fraud it was concocted
by Washington DC politicians who are
such idiots that they could screw up
chocolate cake now you got to work at
that one these politicians are the worst
kind of Ivy League tofu eating snobs on
the planet they're trying to by the vote
of the everyday hard-working man or
woman and that's how the student loan
program was born they wanted to buy your
vote and that's why the stupid thing
even though it's brought more harm to
people than just about anything to come
out of DC that's why it's staying in
place well they want to talk about some
of the left wingers want to talk about
forgiving the loans or providing free
college by raising taxes on rich people
but no one wants to talk about just
ending it because it's bringing harm you
see the people that the student loan
program are screwed the most are people
like me people that grew up like me
people that grew up like Anthony O'Neal
Rams your personality see we didn't grow
up in a neighborhood with college people
the neighborhood I grew up in my parents
my neighbors good hard-working tell the
truth grind it out kind of people they
could teach us how to work hard and they
did like it teaches how to tell the
truth and they did they could teach us
how to stretch a dollar because there
weren't many and they did and they were
the teacher how it'd be the best friend
or the worst enemy a man ever had and
they did but what they couldn't tell us
what how to do is get a four-year degree
cuz almost none of them had one I
counted up the other day either 15 kids
in the neighborhood I grew up in three
of us got a four-year degree and we had
no freakin idea
what we were doing on went off to
college we weren't from that side of the
tracks
people like us believed in getting an
education was important but it was kind
of like when I visited France a couple
summers ago I accidentally ordered
potatoes at lunch because I didn't know
how to speak French that's what happens
when you go on a college campus and you
don't know anything about it and you're
from that side of the tracks people like
me too often wander onto a college
campus with virtually unlimited funds
guaranteed by the federal government to
purchase an education with virtually no
knowledge of what matters in an
education and no limits on how much
stupid damage we can do to our life all
brought to you by a culture that says
education is important so get you some
we well-intentioned four-year degree
seekers were well funded government
ignoramuses we know what we were doing
we had a pocket full of money brought to
you by your Congress federally insured
student loans giving people they don't
know what they're doing the keys to
Ferrari's worse than the lie we were
told that all degrees will make you rich
and famous was that the expensive was
the expensive prestige school lie
because people like me didn't even know
anybody I never knew a soul growing up
that went to an elite private school
with Ivy on the wall unless it was my
daddy's balls or my daddy's boss's boss
I didn't know anybody like that we call
people like that sunburn on the upper
lip because they had their nose in the
air we were told to lies by this culture
one that education is worth whatever it
costs because education is the way up
the socio-economic ladder and to if you
want to make it big you need to go to an
elite muckety-muck school with Ivy on
the wall the only Ivy we knew about was
poison ivy the people I talked to that I
made the dumbest mistakes here on this
show that have been screwed the most by
the federally insured Student Loan
debacle or people like me sometimes
they're black
sometimes they're white sometimes
they're Hispanic but they're always
people like me
the people who call this show that have
the biggest dumbest student loan messes
or people like me they call with
$200,000 in debt from a prestigious
private school to get a master's degree
in sociology what were you thinking oh
you weren't you just order potatoes cuz
you don't know what French is have you
lost your freaking mind what job can you
get with that degree that justifies that
expense I'll help you none or let's get
three hundred twenty-five thousand
dollars in debt from a ripoff prestige
school because I changed my major three
times and end up with an undergrad in
art because the [ __ ] guidance counselor
said to follow my passion that's
malpractice
I'm not against art degrees and I'm not
against a masters in sociology but I am
against a do-nothing era stas
aristocracy Congress with a snobbery of
the worst kind continuing to fund this
lie that is destroying people like me we
need to end the student loan mess now it
needs to stop we need to stop federally
ensuring student loans we're harming our
citizenry this is stupid